Zac Efron got mega-jacked for "Baywatch,"
but he still managed to level up his
physique for the upcoming wrestling
biopic "The Iron Claw." Here's how.
For more than half a century with members spanning
three generations, the Von Erich family has become
legendary in the wrestling world, leading to
their induction into the WWE Hall of Fame in 2009.
On hand to receive this prestigious honor
was Kevin Adkisson, aka Kevin Von Erich,
the last surviving son. The fascinating and tragic
story of Kevin and the rest of the Von Erich
family is the subject of "The Iron Claw," in which
the famous wrestler is portrayed by Zac Efron.
To play the part, Efron had to transform his body
in a massive effort that may be on par with what
he underwent in preparation for "Baywatch," which
is very impressive. However, while that experience
had its upsides, it also had significant downsides
that taught him what worked and what didn't.
"For this movie in particular,
like, we wanted to achieve a look,
and that required a specific type of training."
The actor then took that knowledge and
used it to accomplish the new goal of
increasing his bulk considerably
with great results. Let's take a
look at the vital steps the actor took
to pull off his latest formidable look.
Efron was in incredibly great shape for his role
in "Baywatch," but to achieve those results,
the actor may have pushed himself
to a level exceeding his co-stars.
At the time, Efron was all for putting
the work in, as he told Men's Journal,
"There's this trigger that happens after two or
three weeks of dieting and eating healthy food,
where your body switches its primary energy source
from burning mainly carbohydrates to burning fat."
The actor relished the process because it would
make him crave foods he should be
eating (like sweet potatoes, beets,
and kale) instead of the junk that would
just make his goals harder to accomplish.
On the other hand, the extreme steps it took to
maintain the chiseled abs of a Greek god were
eventually not worth it. A few years after the
film was released, Efron admitted to Men's Health,
"I started to develop insomnia, and I fell
into a pretty bad depression for a long time.
Something about that experience burned me
out. I had a really hard time recentering."
Despite the dark moments, Efron
learned a lot from that experience,
and now fully understands the toll
it takes to have almost no body fat.
"The more you learn, the more
your workouts evolve and change."
By far, the worst part of Efron's "Baywatch"
experience was the need to use pills called
diuretics, which are usually intended
as a treatment for high blood pressure.
According to the Mayo Clinic, diuretics help
remove both sodium and water from your body,
an effect that is very useful when
trying to cut as much weight as possible.
Yet this ended up doing more harm than
good, and was determined as the main
reason for Efron's descent into depression
during filming. As he told Men's Health,
"Ultimately, they chalked it up to taking
way too many diuretics for way too long,
and it messed something up."
Fortunately, to play Kevin Von Erich in
"The Iron Claw," none of that was needed,
and the actor has preferred it
that way going forward. He added,
"That 'Baywatch' look, I don't know if
that's really attainable. There's just
too little water in the skin. Like, it's fake;
it looks CGI'd. [...] I much prefer to have
an extra, you know, 2 to 3 percent body fat."
"I was not happy, not eating carbs."
There are certainly aspects of Efron's intense
preparation for his "Baywatch" body that he will
not do again for future projects, such as the
use of diuretics and some of the strict dietary
choices. However, going into beast mode for
workouts is something that he doesn't regret.
For the film, he trained two times a
day, five or six days out of the week,
but that didn't seem to bother
him. He explained to Men's Journal,
"When I'm very careful about my
fitness and have a goal in mind,
it keeps me motivated and balanced.
I wake up earlier. I don't feel the
need to be out — that kills your day,
your hobbies, and your motivation."
That same mentality came in handy for Efron as he
bulked up considerably for "The Iron
Claw." The actor told Men's Health,
"I enjoy pushing myself and
really laying it all out,
to the point where I kind of have to do
it. Otherwise, I don't feel like myself."
For his films since "Baywatch," Efron has
had a significantly healthier approach
to meals during shoots. In a diet-focused
exclusive for Men's Health, the actor said,
"Sometimes when you're on set, I
give myself permission now to sort
of let up and eat what I need to eat.
It's not the time or the place to put
pressure on yourself unless you really
need to be shirtless that entire film."
The far less restrictive behavior has not only
allowed him to avoid a lot of stress, but those
extra calories have also been essential for the
bulking up he needed to do for "The Iron Claw."
According to Healthline, the best way to
build muscle is to eat more food than the
body needs while carrying out intense
weightlifting. Based on the trailer,
the added calories and Efron's vigor for
workouts were a highly effective combination.
For some time, Efron's veganism helped him
achieve his lean build, but eventually he realized
that the restrictive diet was not great for his
health. With that in mind, the actor transitioned
to eating habits that worked better for his
body. When talking with Men's Health, he said,
"I started intermittent fasting just
after I stopped being vegan. My body
wasn't processing the vegetables in
the right way, so I decided to stop
it and try something new. Intermittent
fasting's been really helpful with that."
Although it is possible to
be a vegan and still bulk up,
there is no denying that adding meats and
dairy products to the diet makes the process
considerably easier. According to Healthline,
bodybuilders rely on nutrient-dense foods high
in protein and healthy fats. While the
Efron may not have known it at the time,
the switch turned out to be a great
decision in preparation for "The Iron Claw."
To show his commitment not just to bulking for
"The Iron Claw," but to using a protein-rich
diet to achieve that body goal, Efron met the
interviewer for Men's Health at a steakhouse
in Thousand Oaks, California. The proof
that his veganism was long over came as
he ordered a Wagyu steak and sides, along
with a seafood tower to start it all off.
Efron then went on to explain that the
switch to focusing on protein-heavy foods
made him feel significantly less
exhausted after intense workouts,
but a part of him also wished that
was not the case. The actor admitted,
"Morally, of course, I still wish I was vegan."
Yet at the same time, he also
seemed to have enjoyed the change,
based on the way he praised the Wagyu
steak once it arrived at the table,
telling his interviewer, "that's
why I'm not vegan anymore."
For "Baywatch," Efron pushed his body to the
max and paid the price afterwards by throwing
out his back, tearing his ACL, breaking
his wrist, and dislocating his shoulder.
The actor learned his lesson the hard
way that if he was going into beast mode,
he must also be just as extreme in his recovery.
Through his Instagram, Efron shares his extreme
but successful solutions to relax his muscles,
like entering a cryotherapy chamber post-workout.
But of all the methods that the actor adopted,
immersing himself in ice-cold water gave him
the best results. He told Men's Health how ice
baths had become a vital part of his routine:
"It's my favorite part of the day.
Before is when it's most miserable,
and when you finally just commit and
jump in there. From that point forward,
you've conquered something deep within
you; you do not want to get cold. That's
the simplest philosophy: Anything you
don't want to do, make it a habit."
Given the high level of strain he had to
put his muscles through in the bodybuilding
process for "The Iron Claw," it sounds like the
freezing-cold recovery is exactly what he needed.
Almost every single day during the
production of "Baywatch," all Efron
consumed was lean meat or fish with sweet
potatoes. Although the extremely limited
diet produced the desired results, he would
prefer not to go that route in the future.
"That was the most extreme I ever got. I
think I was in ketosis that entire film."
To play Kevin Von Erich in "The Iron
Claw," Efron still relied on unprocessed,
nutrient-rich foods, but incorporated
a good amount of variety as well. When
talking with Men's Health, the actor laid
out his improved regimen in full, saying,
"First meal of the day usually
starts with bone broth; I really
love bone broth. It's satisfying
and it's good for your stomach."
Moving on to something more substantial,
his next meal typically consisted of,
"Some sort of veggies with a
really clean source of protein,
whether it's chicken, beef,
venison, elk, anything."
Efron then ended with the most
calorie-dense part of the day,
to provide his muscles with the energy
needed to bulk up. He told Men's Health,
"I usually have my highest carbohydrate
meal sort of in the evening. That's usually
another really good source of meat and healthy
carbohydrate like sweet potatoes or quinoa."
When an actor undergoes a major
body transformation for a role,
it's always great praise if the real-life person
they're supposed to play compliments their
achievement. This is especially the case with Zac
Efron in "The Iron Claw," because Kevin Von Erich
himself was thoroughly impressed with what he
has seen so far. The former wrestler told TMZ,
"I saw a picture of the guy, he looked great.
I don't think I ever looked that good."
As an athlete himself, Kevin is
fully aware of what it took for
Efron to bulk up like he did. The wrestler added,
"He must really be working out hard.
[...] He does have a good body."